this is an amazing beginner's angular
course slobodan is a very experienced
developer and he teaches the basics of
angular using diagrams animations and of
course code
today i'm starting with a new video
series about angular framework and in
this series you will learn all the
things you need to master angular
framework
i'll start with basic stuff like
components and pipes and slowly progress
the most complex features of this
framework so let's start
in this section i'm gonna explain what
angular is give some brief overview of
its features and explain why you should
use it
but before we start make sure to check
my channel for more videos and tutorials
about front-end development now let's
start
angular is opinionated ui framework for
building mobile and desktop applications
and it's built using typescript by
google you probably heard about that one
also it is an open source and helps us
build dynamic and single page
applications
it is completely based on components
it consists of several components which
forms a tree structure with parent and
child components angular's versions
beyond 2 plus are generally known as
angular only
the very first version of angular is
known as angularjs
so why angular
well because it's supported on various
platforms we have mobile desktop native
it's powerful modern has nice ecosystem
and it's just cool not convinced
let me give you some facts
angular presents you not only the tools
but also design patterns to build your
project in a maintainable way
when an angular application is crafted
properly you don't end up with a tangle
of classes and methods that are hard to
modify and even harder to test the code
is structured conveniently and you won't
need to spend much time in order to
understand what is going on
it's javascript but better
angular is built with typescript which
in turn relies on js es6
you don't need to learn a totally new
language but you still receive features
like static typing interfaces classes
namespaces decorators etc
no need to reinvent the bicycle with
angular you already have lots of tools
to start crafting the application right
way you have directives to give html
elements dynamic behavior you can power
up the forms using form control and
introduce various validation rules
you may easily send asynchronous http
requests of various types
you can set up routing with little
hassle
and there are many more goodies that
angular can offer us
components are decoupled
angular strive to remove the tie
coupling between various components of
the application
injection happens in node.js style and
you may replace various components with
ease
all dawn manipulation happens where it
should happen
with angular you don't tightly couple
presentation and application logic
making your markup much cleaner and
simpler
testing is at the heart
angular is meant to be thoroughly tested
and it supports both unit and end-to-end
testing
angular is mobile and desktop-ready
meaning you have one framework for
multiple platforms
angular is actively maintained and has a
large community and ecosystem you can
find lots of materials on this framework
as well as many useful third-party tools
the architecture diagram indentifies the
eight main building blocks of an angular
application
angular apps are modular and an angular
has its own modularity system called
angular modules or ng modules
every angular app has at least one
angular module class the road module
conveniently named app module
while the root module may be the only
module in a small application
most apps have many more feature modules
each a cohesive block of code dedicated
to an application domain a workflow or a
closely related set of capabilities
an angular module whether a route or a
feature is a class with a ng module
decorator
angular templates are dynamic
when angular renders them it transforms
the dom according to the instructions
given by directives
metadata tells angular how to process a
class
service is a broad category encompassing
any value function or feature that your
application needs
almost anything can be a service a
service is typical a class with a narrow
well-defined purpose it should do
something specific
and do it well
examples include
logging service data service
message bus
tax calculator application configuration
there is nothing specifically about
angular services
angular has no definition of a service
there is no service based class and no
place to register a service
yet services are fundamental to any
angular application
components are big consumers of services
now let's talk more about components in
detail
components are the main building block
of angular application each component
consists of an html template that
declares what renders on the page a
typescript class that defines behavior a
css selector that defines how the
component is used in a template and
optionally css styles applied to the
component
a component must belong to an ng module
in order for it to be available to
another component
why do we use components
there are many reasons but the main ones
are we are able to reuse our code so we
don't duplicate it
simplify component based architecture
easy to do error handling
and breaking down the complexity into
smaller pieces
prerequisites for these sections are
install the angular cli and create an
angular workspace with initial
application
if you don't have a project you can
create one using ng-new project name
where project name is the name of your
application
although the angular cli is the easiest
way to create an angular component in
this tutorial we will create our
component manually
to create a new component navigate your
angular project directory create a new
file hello world component ts file
at the top of the file add the following
import statement
after the import statement add a
component decorator decorator marks a
class as an angular component and
provides metadata that decides how the
component is used at runtime
choose css selector for the component
this is the tag which you will be using
in your template files to render your
component
define the html template that the
component uses to display information in
most cases this template is a separate
html file
but i'll use it within this file
to define a template as external file
add a template url property to the
component decorator for a template
within the same file use template
property
select the styles for the components
template in most cases you defined the
styles for your components template in a
separate file again i will use it within
the file to declare the styles for a
component in a separate file add a style
urls property to the it component
decorator
but for the styles within the component
add styles property
add a class statement that includes the
code for the component
here we can define properties methods
catch component lifecycle events and do
dependency ejection but i'll talk more
about these in the next video
now all the public properties that you
define in the class are accessible in
the html template and this is one of the
most powerful things here
i'll create a title property
and i will include it in the html
import that new file in the module where
you want to use it to make it available
for the whole app imported in the root
module
in order to see our component we can use
our css selector inside of our app
component or any other component
and this is your first component very
simple though which you can reuse across
your app
in this section we are talking about
lifecycle hooks there are special
functionality in angular that allows us
to hook into and run code at a specific
lifecycle event of a component or
directive
you can look at them as phases of
component life like every living being
has they get born they change they grow
and eventually they die with life cycle
hooks you can gain better control of our
application when do we want to use them
for example if you want to fetch some
data and display it in your component
you will do that inside of ngoninit
lifecycle when it component gets
initialized or if you need to clean up
your component remove some subscriptions
you might have to prevent memory leaks
you will do that inside of ng on destroy
lifecycle hook just before component
gets destroyed
this is the list of all hooks in exact
order how they get initialized but most
used ones are on init on changes and on
destroy
let's implement the ng oninit hook as
you will be using this hook the most
first import oninit interface from
angular core
next we want to implement this interface
inside of our class
to implement any hook you just need to
add an ng to the interface name and you
will get the method needed for
implementation
so in this case it's ng on init we will
create a simple function for logging
some values to the console now i will
create a property that will save that
function so that we can clean it up at
the end
in the ng on init method let's create a
simple set interval method which will
make a console log on every second
if you leave our component like this
when the component gets destroyed our
interval method will continue to log to
console to fix this side effect we need
to use the ng on destroy hook
import on destroy interface and place it
next to oninit
now create the ng on destroy method and
in this method you need to clean up this
interval
simply use a clear interval method with
our property passed as an argument
and now our component has been cleaned
up using lifecycle hooks we can
fine-tune the behavior of our components
during creation update and destruction
next text interpolation
text interpolation in angular is a
one-way data binding technique that is
used to transfer the data from a test
script code to an html template
it uses the template expression in
double curly braces also known as a
mustache syntax to display the data from
the component to the view when do we
need text interpolation every time we
want to make something dynamic in our
html template
to illustrate how interpolation works
let's create a new variable in our ts
class
you can use interpolation to display the
value of this variable in the
corresponding component template
angular replaces title with the string
value of the corresponding component
property
in this case the value is hello world
now let's talk about template
expressions
a template expression produces a value
and appears within double curly braces
let me show you an example
angular resolves the expression and
assigns it to a property of a binding
target
template expressions are similar to
javascript except you can't use
assignments also operators such as new
type off or instasoft you can't use
chaining expressions decrement or
increment operators and some of the es
2015 plus operators
expressions can also invoke methods so
let's create one
name of our method will be get min
and in this method we are returning
value for displaying it in our template
in this case it will be a minimum value
couple things i want to mention
you should keep application logic in the
component as much as possible
where it is easier to develop and test
also expressions should finish quickly
to keep the user experience as efficient
as possible especially on slower devices
and template expression should not
change any application state other than
the value of the target property
reading and component value should not
change some other displayed values
[Music]
now let's learn how to communicate
between the components
an angular application usually consists
of many separated components and in
order to make them work together we need
communication between them
you can think of components as family
members and if communication between the
parents and kids is fluent and efficient
your home will be a happy place
there are four ways to communicate
between the angular components
binding using input and output
reference by using view child and
content child provider using services
and template outlet
in this tutorial i'm gonna cover the
first two ways as we haven't covered
services yet and a template output is a
little bit advanced
first use case is when we want to send
data from parent to child using input
decorator
input decorator takes the value pass
from parent and stores that value in the
child property
let me create two components using
angular cli
i will run the following commands
ng generate component parent
and ng generate component child
in our child component i will import
input decorator and name our input as
child message of type string
in the template of the same component i
will display this property which is
going to be passed from a parent
now
inside of our parent component in the
template we want to place our child
component and to pass the value to the
input property we just created
the name of the property is the one we
defined in the child component and the
value is going to be a hello message
next we want to place our parent
component inside of our root component
and if we preview it we can see that our
message from parent has been displayed
in our child component
second use case is when we want to send
data from child to parent using output
decorator
output decorator marks a property in a
child component as a doorway through
which data can travel from the child to
the parent
this approach is ideal when you want to
share data that occurs on things like
button click form entries and other user
events
to raise an event an output must have
the type of event emitter which is a
class in the angular core that used to
emit custom events
in the child component import output
decorator and event emitter
we declare a message event variable with
output decorator and set it to equal to
a new event emitter
then we create a function named send
message that calls a mid on this event
with the message we want to send
lastly we create a button to trigger
this function
in the parent i will create a function
to receive the message and i will just
simply alert this message for
demonstration purposes
now in the parent template
call our function once the event from
the child component occurs
and the name of that event is the one
that we defined with output decorator
very simple and effective
compared with all other approaches for
communication binding is the cleanest
and the simplest one
it is the most maintainable way for
passing data
hence binding is always the most
preferable way that angular developers
should consider first
third use case is when we want to send
data from child to parent using view
child
view child allows the child component to
be injected into a parent component
it will give the parent access to its
properties and functions
a child won't be available to give
access until the view has been
initialized
this means we need to implement the
after-view init lifecycle hook to
receive the data from the child
first create a message property in our
child component
import view child and after view init
from angular core and our child
component
for our view child decorator pass our
child component as an argument and name
it as child
next implement after view init lifecycle
hook
by the way to learn more about angular
hooks check the part 2 of this video
series
inside the ng after view init method
just alert the message property of our
child so that you can see that we have
access to it
and if we start our application you can
see that we are displaying a message
from the child component
[Music]
next we are discussing component styles
being able to style your app is very
important because it allows you to make
your app unique and attractive in a way
it's like a beauty salon
world without css would be an ugly place
css gives us the opportunity to play
with a page layout adjust colors and
fonts add effects to images and so on
how to add styles to angular components
there are three ways you can apply style
by setting style or style urls metadata
inline the template html
and three with css imports
i created one blank component with only
h2 tag in the view to demonstrate all
different ways we can style it you can
add a styles array property to the
component decorator
each string in the array defines some
css for this component
you can load styles from external css
files
by adding a styles url property to a
component's decorator
and now styles from external file are
being applied
next you can embed css styles directly
into the html template by putting them
inside of style tags
you can also write link tags into the
component's html template
one note here is to be sure to include
the link styles file among the assets to
be copied to the server when building
you can also import css files into the
css files using the standard css import
rule
i usually use this approach to import
the variables
reminder
these styles apply only to this
component
so if you have h1 tag in a child or
parent component it won't be applied
there
by default view encapsulation is set to
emulated and emulates the behavior of
the shadow dom by pre-processing and
renaming css code to effectively scope
the css to the components view
we can remove these additional css
selectors by setting encapsulation to
none
and now our styles are being applied
globally
global styles are by default defined in
the style css file and you can define
more global styles in the angular json
file
another thing is that if you're building
with the cli you can write style files
in sas less or stylus and specify those
files in the component style urls
metadata with the appropriate extension
as in the following example
now let's talk about special selectors
use the host pseudo class selector to
target styles in the element that hosts
the component as opposite to target
elements inside the components template
for example we can write the following
code
we can style host styles with the given
selector by using the function form as
the following
and if you add active class to host
component you can see that styles are
being applied
now let's talk about host context
sometimes it's useful to apply styles
based on some condition outside of the
components view
for example a css theme class could be
applied to the document body element
and you want to change how your
component looks based on that
the following example applies a
background color style to all h2
elements inside of the component only if
ancestor elements has the css class
theme light
now if you go to root element and add
theme light class you can see those
styles
and that's it
[Music]
now let's see what is ng content
ng content uses the content projection
to take html of another component and to
display it inside itself
to me it's similar to a film projector
where you have a slot to insert your
content which is going to be displayed
on the screen
it's a very powerful tool when you're
building components intended for reuse
i see it used extensively in frameworks
such as ng material
when they want to use ng content
anytime you want to inject any kind of
html into a component you can do so with
ng content
i have two components child and root
component to demonstrate this feature
inside the child component i will create
some static content so i'll add h2 title
and below that title i want to show the
dynamic content
so i will create an ng content tag
with the ng content element in place
users of this component can now project
their own message into the component
to do that let me insert a child inside
of our root component
and i will pass a paragraph with a
message
as you can see the ng content element is
a placeholder that does not create a
real dom element
now except single a component can have a
multiple slots
each slot can specify a css selector
that determines which content goes into
that slot
this pattern is referred to as
multi-slot content projection
you can accomplish this task by using
the select attribute of ng content
inside of our child component add one
more ng content tag
we can make our component to be like a
question and ask a card
so in the first engine content add
question selector and for the second ng
content add answer selector
now we can use these selectors to send
different content
in our root component i will create h3
title with a question selector and i
will type this question text
below i will create a paragraph with an
answer selector and i will type an
answer text
also there are a couple other ways to
create multislot content projection but
we haven't covered conditionals yet
as you can see
it's really easy to create reusable
dynamic components this approach can be
used for much more complex user
interfaces but i showed you this simple
example to understand the concept
next let's discuss template statements
a template statement is something that
responds to an event raised by a target
like an element component or directive
so it's the same thing as if someone is
calling you which is an event and you're
answering that phone call which is the
response and in our example template
statement
it commits side effects as it changes
the fields in the component
now i will show you how to update class
properties using a template statement
i have a blend component and in our
template i will create a boolean
property named show text be the value of
false
below that i will create a method named
toggle text it's not going to return
anything at this point
all we are going to do here is to toggle
our show text value on every method call
usually we would use this kind of
property to toggle the state in the view
but we haven't covered conditionals yet
so in the template i'm gonna create a
button which will respond on a click
event and it will call this toggle
method
below that i will just display our show
tax property
and now when i click the button you can
see that it toggles its value using
template statement and in this example
toggle text is template statement
this statement context may also refer to
properties of the template's own context
in the following example toggle text
takes the template's own event object as
an argument
if you log that object you can see that
it contains various information about
the target and the event that occurred
passing arguments can be very useful
when you're submitting the forms or
looping through arrays and you need to
access a specific element
one note here is that the context of a
template statement can be the component
class instance or the template because
of this template statements cannot refer
to anything the global namespace such as
window or document for example template
statement can't call console.log or
mathmax
pipes
pipes are simply functions you can use
in your templates to accept an input
value and return a format head value
in this case you can see your data as
untouched clay which is ready to be mold
at the beginning it's not very nice or
clear what it's for but with a little
bit of crafting and molding you can get
the end results that you wanted
angular provides built-in pipes for
typical data transformation like bait
pipe uppercase pipe currency pipe
percent pipe and similar
in my app component i will define a date
property with the value of new date
if we just display our date object in
our template you can see what kind of
format we get
it's not very user friendly
now let's make it nicer
to apply a pipe use the pipe operator
within a template expression along with
the name of the pipe which is the date
for the built-in date pipe now this is
much more readable
one out here datepipe is executed only
but it detects a pure change to the
input value a pure change is either a
change to a primitive input value such
as string
number boolean or symbol or a changed
object reference such as date array
function or object
if you still don't like the output
format of your date you can fine tune it
by using optional parameters
there are predefined options like short
or long
and others
or you can customize it completely
for example i'll write four e's for a
day in a week four m's for a month one
lowercase d for a day in a month and one
lowercase y for a year
you can also chain multiple pipes as
well
you just add another pipe operator and a
pipe name
now we can create custom pipes as well
let's create a simple greetings pipe
that will concatenate hello to past name
i'll use angular cli to generate this
file for me so type ng
generate pipe and the name is greetings
pipe
in our pipe we have boilerplate code
generated
you can see that pipe decorator has been
imported with a name property which we
can use to call our pipe in our
templates
also there is a pipe transform interface
which needs to be implemented
this interface requires the transform
method to be implemented and this method
receives a value passed from a template
in our case it will be a string
and the second parameter is for optional
params from pipe itself
return type in our case is going to be a
string
now all we are going to do here is to
concatenate hello on the path string and
return that
now in our template we can call our
custom pipe with the greetings pipe name
that we defined
and i will pass world as our string
now that's how you create a custom pipes
angular pipes are very simple but useful
functionality provided by angular and
you will use them a lot
once again for a detailed list of all
pipes check the documentation link from
the description
now let's discuss property binding
property binding moves a value in one
direction so you can see it as one-way
street
you can't go the other way
value goes from class property to target
element property
property binding in angular helps you
set values or properties of html
elements or directives
with property binding you can do things
as google button functionality set paths
programmatically and share values
between components
to bind the source property of an image
element to a component's property
place the target source in the square
brackets followed by an equal sign and
then the property
the property here is item image url
declare the item image url property in
the class
in this case app component
a common point of confusion is between
the attribute call span and the property
call span
notice that these two names differ by
only a single letter
if you wrote something like this you'd
get template parse error
interpolation and property binding can
set only properties not attributes
instead you'd use property binding and
write it like this
another example is disabling a button
when the component says that it's
unchanged
to disable a button's functionality
depending on a boolean value binding
down disable property to a property in
the class that's true or false
because the value of the property is
unchanged it shows in the app component
angular disables the button
often interpolation and property binding
can achieve the same result
the following binding pairs do the same
thing
one note
evaluation of a template expression
should have no visible side effects
you shouldn't be assigning anything in
the template expression or using
increment or decrement operators
if you had an expression that changed
the value of something else that you
were binding to
the change of value would be a side
effect
[Music]
now let's see what our attribute class
and style windings
using these bindings you can improve
accessibility dynamically style your
application and update classes on the
fly
first let's talk about attribute binding
attribute binding in angular helps you
set values for attributes directly
it is recommended that you set an
element property with a property binding
whenever possible
however sometimes you don't have an
element property to bind in those
situations you can use attribute binding
attribute binding syntax resembles
property binding but instead of an
element property between brackets you
proceed the name of the attribute with
prefix attr followed by a dot
then you set the attribute value with an
expression that resolves to a string
another common use case for attribute
binding is with the call span attribute
in tables mining the call span attribute
helps you keep your tables
programmatically dynamic
depending on the amount of data that
your application populates a table with
the number of columns that a row span
could change
to use attribute binding with the td
attribute callspan specify the call span
attribute by using this syntax
set attribute call span equal to an
expression
in this example we bind the call span
attribute to the expression one plus one
this binding causes the table row to
span two columns
sometimes there are differences between
the name of property and an attribute
call span is an attribute of table row
while call span with the capital s is a
property when using attribute binding
use call span with a lowercase s
for more information on how to bind to
the call spam property check out the
video about the property binding
now let's move to class binding you can
use class binding to add and remove css
class names from an elements class
attribute
to create a single class binding use the
prefix class followed by a dot and the
name of the css class
angular adds the class when the bound
expression on sale is truthy
and it removes the class when the
expression is falsy
with the exception of undefined
to bind the multiple classes use class
set to an expression
the expression can be one of a space
delimited string of class names
and objective class names as the keys
and thirty all policy expressions as the
values
an array of class names
with the object format angular adds a
class only if its associated value is
truthy
and finally let's talk about style
binding
you can use style binding to set styles
dynamically to create a single style
binding use the prefix style followed by
a dot in the name of the css style
property
angular sets the property to the value
of the bound expression which is usually
a string
optionally you can add a unit extension
like m or a percentage which requires a
number type
you can write a style property name in
either dash case or camel case
to toggle multiple styles bind to the
style attribute
the style expression
the style expression can be one of a
string list of
styles or an object with style names as
the keys and style values as the values
and note that binding an array to style
is not supported
[Music]
this time i'm talking about event
binding event binding allows you to
listen for and respond to user actions
such as keystroke mouse movements clicks
and touches it's similar to float
fishing as you're waiting for a fish to
take your bite and once it drips off you
respond quickly and strike
to bind an event you use the angular
event binding syntax
this syntax consists of an event name
within parentheses to the left of an
equal sign and a template statement to
the right
in this example the event name is click
and the template statement is on save
we can now define the unsave method in
rts class
and once we click our button that event
has been bound and our method is
executed
we can also bind to custom events to
demonstrate that i'll create an item
details component
in this component i'll create an event
emitter with output decorator which
exposes our property to parent
components
then i'll create a delete dummy method
which will just emit our property once
we call it
now
i'll define a button and bind this
method to a click event
next i'll place our item details
component in our app component and i
will bind to the delete request custom
event that we just created
i'm calling delete item method and i'll
use the event parameter to cache the
string sent with this event
and now i'll define the delete item
method in our class and just log what we
got
and that's how you bind to a custom
event
[Music]
now let's see two-way binding in action
two-way binding is the concept of
sharing and giving what you give is what
you can expect from others why two-way
binding toy binding gives components in
your application a way to share data
use two-way binding to listen for events
and update values simultaneously between
parent and child components
angular's two-way binding syntax is a
combination of square brackets and
parentheses
this syntax combines the brackets of the
property binding with the parentheses of
event binding
i'll create a sizer component
in our component i will define a size
value property in a size change event
the size property is an input so data
can flow into the sizer component
the size change event is an output which
allows data to flow out of the sizer
component to the parent component
next there are two methods deck to
decrease the font size and ink to
increase the font
size these two methods use resize to
change the value of the size property
within min max value constraints
and to emit an event that conveys the
new size value
in the sizer component template i'll
create two buttons that each bind the
click event to the ink and deck methods
when the user clicks one of the buttons
the sizer component
calls the corresponding method
both methods ink and deck called the
resize method with a plus one or minus
one which in turn raises the site change
event with the new size value
and below them i'll add a label which
displays size property and dynamically
updates its own font size
in our root app component i'll include
an app sizer component and i will use
two-way binding to bind font-size px
property to the sizer component
and below that i'll add a div which will
utilize this property to adjust its text
size
in the app component font size px
establishes the initial sizer component
size value by setting the value to 16.
clicking the button updates the app
component font size bx
the revised font size px value updates
the style binding which makes the
display text bigger or smaller
the two-way binding syntax is shorthand
for a combination of property binding
and event binding the sizer component
binding a separate property binding
and event binding is as follows
the event variable contains the data of
the sizer component size change event
angular assigns the event value to app
component font size px when the user
clicks the buttons
to use two-way binding with form
elements we need ng-model which i will
cover in the form section
next ones are template variables
template variables helps you to use data
from one part of a template in another
part of a template
it's a variable that is created in and
identifies a component or element within
the template itself so it's like a phone
number of a component which you can use
to call it in case you need something
from it
with template variables you can perform
tasks such as respond to user input or
finely tune your application's form
syntax
in the template you use the hash symbol
to declare a template variable
the following template variable phone
declares a phone variable on an input
element
you can refer to a template variable
anywhere in the components template
here a button further down the template
refers to the form variable
now we can define the call font method
and log the past value which is the
actual value of the input
so what is the template variable scope
you can refer to a template variable
anywhere within its surrounding template
structural directives such as ngif and
ng4 which we'll cover in the later
videos or ng template act as a template
boundary
you cannot access template variables
outside of these boundaries
so
can we access variables in a nested
template
an inline template can access template
variables that the outer template
defines
in the following example changing the
text in the input changes the value in
the span because angular immediately
updates changes to the template variable
ref1
in this case there is an implied ng
template around the span and the
definition of the variable is outside of
it
so it's the same thing as writing it
explicitly like this
however accessing a template variable
from outside the parent template doesn't
work
it's the same as writing the following
and that's all for template variables
now let's discuss directives
it's the same as if you are a ceo of the
company and you are giving directives to
your employees how to behave and what to
do in certain situations
what are directives
directives are classes that add
additional behavior to elements in your
angular application
with angular built-in directives you can
manage forms lists styles and what users
see
the different type of angular directives
are as follows
components directives with a template
this type of directive is the most
common directive type
attribute directives
directives that change the appearance or
behavior of an element component or
another directive
structural directives
directives that change the dom layout by
adding and removing dom elements today
we are talking about built-in attribute
directives
attribute directive listens to and
modify the behavior of other html
elements attributes properties and
components
many ng modules such as router module
and forums module define their own
attribute directives the most common
attribute directives are as follows
ng-class adds and removes a set of css
classes
ng-style adds and removes a set of html
styles
ng model adds two-way data binding to an
html form element
how to add and remove classes with
ng-class
you can add or remove multiple css
classes simultaneously with ng-class to
add or remove a single class use class
binding rather than ng class
when the element you'd like to style add
ng class and set it to equal to an
expression
in narrow class let's define is special
as true
because especially is true energy class
applies the class of special to the div
to use ngclass with a method add method
to the component class
in the following example
set current classes sets the property
current classes with an object that adds
or removes three classes based on the
true or false state of three other
component properties
each key of the object is a css class
name
if a k is a true ng class adds the class
if a key is false energy class removes
the class
boolean values are hard coded just for
demonstration
in the template add the ng class
property binding to current class to set
the elements classes
and now we can preview our classes
now let's talk about ng style
you can use ng-style to set multiple
inline styles simultaneously based on
the state of the component
to use ng style add the method to
component class
add empty object current style
in the following example set current
styles sets the property current styles
with an object that defines three styles
to set element styles add an ng style
property binding to current styles
for this use case angular applies the
styles upon initializations
and in case of changes
to do this the full example called set
current styles initially with ng on in
it
and the last one in today's video is ng
model
you can use the ng model directive to
display a data property and update that
property when the user make changes
import forms module and add it to ng
modules import list
i'll create a label and an input for
this example
add an ng model binding of an html form
element and set it equal to the property
here its name now if we define property
inside of our component class you can
see how ng model directive adds two-way
data binding to our input
this ng-model syntax can only set a
data-bound property
when you write an angular component you
don't need a value accessor or ng model
if your name the value and even
properties according to angular's
two-way binding syntax and that's all
for this section
in this section we are continuing with
angle directives let's build attribute
directive
let's create a file highlight dot
directive dot yes
which is the convention that you always
should follow
next import directive decorator from
core and implement that decorator with
selector property
for me it's going to be app highlight
next we want to export our
class the last thing we want is to
import that in our declarations array in
app module
that's our directive boilerplate code
which you can also get with the command
ng generate directive highlight
import element ref from angular core
element ref grants direct access to the
host dom element through its native
element property add element ref in the
directives constructor to inject a
reference to host dom element the
element to which you apply app highlight
add logic to the highlight directive
class that sets the background to yellow
to use the highlight directive add a
paragraph element to the html template
with the directive as an attribute
angular creates an instance of highlight
directive class and injects in reference
to the paragraph element into directives
constructor which sets the p element's
background style to yellow now let's see
how to detect when a user mouses into or
out of the element and to respond by
setting or clearing the highlight color
import host listener from angular core
add two event handlers that respond when
the mouse enters or leaves each with the
host listener decorator
with the host listener decorator you can
subscribe to events of the dom element
that hosts an attribute directive the
paragraph in this case
the handlers delegate to a helper method
highlight that sets the color on the
host home element l
the background color appears when the
pointer hovers over the paragraph
element and disappears as the pointer
moves out
now let's see how we can make the
directive dynamic to be able to use it
at different places with different
colors
in highlight directive ts file import
inputs from angular core
add an app highlight input property
the input decorator adds metadata to the
class that makes the directive app
highlight property available for binding
in app component ts add a color property
to the app component
to simultaneously apply the directive
and the color use the property binding
with the f highlight directive selector
setting to equal to color
the amp highlight attribute binding
performs two tasks applies the
highlighting directive to the paragraph
element
and sets directive highlight color with
the property binding
and that's all for this one
[Music]
this is the last section about
directives so let's see what are
structural directives
structural directives are responsible
for html layout they shape or reshape
the dom structure typically by adding
removing and manipulating the host
elements to which they are attached
this section introduces the most common
built-in structure directives
ngif
conditionally creates or disposes of
subviews from the template
ng4
repeat a node for each item in a list
ng switch
a set of directives that switch among
alternative views
you can add or remove an element by
applying an ngif directive to a host
element
when ngif is false
angular removes an element and its
descendants from the dom
angular then disposes of their
components which frees up memory and
resources
to add or remove an element bind ng if
to a condition expression such as
is active in this example
when there is active expression returns
a true value ngif adds the div to the
dom
when the expression is falsy ngf removes
the dim from the dom
that's simpler right
now let's talk about ng4
you can use the ng4 directive to present
a list of items
let's create an array of objects with
the name property in it
define a block of html that determines
how angular renders a single item
to list your items assigned the
shorthand let item of items to ng4
the string led item of items instructs
angular to do the following
store each item in the items array in
the local item looping variable
make each item available to the template
html for each iteration
translate let item of items into ng
template around the host element
repeat the ng template for each item in
the list
by the way you can get the index of ng4
in a template input variable and use it
in the template
in the ng4 add a semicolon and let i
equals to index to the shorthand
the following example gets the index in
a variable named i and displays it
within the item name
and the last directive which we are
going to talk about is switch
like the javascript switch statement ng
switch displays one element from among
several possible elements based on a
switch condition
angular puts only the selected element
into the dom
ng switch is a set of three directives
ng switch an attribute directive that
changes the behavior of its companion
directives
ng switch case
structural directive that adds its
element to the dom when its bound value
equals the switch value and removes its
bound value when it doesn't equal the
switch value
ng switch default structural directive
that adds its element to the dom when
there is no selected ng switch case
i'll modify the items array to be just a
single item
on an element such as a div add ng
switch bound to an expression that
returns the switch value such as a name
though the name value in this example is
a string the switch value can be of any
type
bind to ng switch case and ng switch
default on the elements for the cases
and now depending on the value of the
item name rendering of the page changes
if you didn't provide a case for the
name value default will be executed
[Music]
next we are discussing dependency
injection
dependencies are services or objects
that a class needs to perform its
function
dependency injection or di is a design
pattern in which a class requests
dependencies from external sources
rather than creating them
you can look at it as if you are adding
an extension to your browser or adding
an app to your phone
once you add it you provide yourself
with the new functionalities and
features nice extension
let's create a service which we can
inject in our components create a new
file with the name log.service.ds
import injectable decorator from angular
core
and then for provided in metadata add
root value
which means that we are going to provide
the service in the root of the
application
and that it's visible throughout the
application
export our log service class and inside
of this service we want to add our log
message method
which will just log past messages
for clarity and maintainability it is
recommended that you define components
and services in separate files now
inject our log service into the app
module file in providers array
injecting service results in making them
visible to a component
to inject a dependency in components
constructor supply a constructor
argument with dependency type the
following example specifies the log
service in the app component constructor
the type of log service is log service
now we can reference our log service in
our component and call our method from
it
we should pass our message and as you
can see it's being executed as expected
we can use this approach to inject
third-party libraries and other modules
that are available in angular framework
so let's inject render 2 module which is
used for custom rendering and updating
the dom
import renderer 2 from angular core and
inject it inside the constructor
also we will need element graph which we
can use for referencing our dom elements
or the host component in our case
now inside the ng unit life cycle call
the set style method of the renderer and
set the color of host native element to
red
this method changes the color of our
components text and as you can see with
the dependency injection we get access
to more features and methods
that's all there is to it
[Music]
next is very important topic
routing the angular router is a core
part of angular platform it enables
developers to build single page
applications with multiple views and
allow navigation between these views
we can compare routing of our
applications with navigating a plane
pilot sets the flight coordinates in our
case route path and the plane lands on
the desired location or desired page in
our app
oftentimes planes carries goods or cargo
and routes carry params info and data
and unfortunately some planes do get
crashed or lost and for out sometimes we
get 404.
to use the angular router an application
needs to have at least two components so
that it can navigate from one to other
to create a component using the cli
enter the following at the command line
where first is the name of your
component
ng generate component first
repeat this step for a second component
but give it a different name here the
new name is second
this guide works with a cli generated
angular application
if you are working manually make sure
that you have base href with slash in
the head of your index.html file
this assumes that the app folder is the
application root and that uses slash
create a new module for routing
name it app dash routing dot module
define const routes which is type of
routes
here we will define our paths and
components
inside ng module imports array add
router module and call for root module
it routes past as argument
then export your router module so it can
be imported into the root module
at the end define the app routing module
class
import the app routing module into app
module and add it to the imports array
now define your routes in your routes
array
each route in this array is a javascript
object that contains two properties the
first property path defines the url path
for the route the second property
component defines the component that
angular should use for the corresponding
path
now that you have defined your routes
you can add them to your application
first add links to the two components
assign the anchor tag that you want to
add the route to the router link
attribute
set the value of the attribute to the
component to show when a user clicks on
each link
next
update your component template to
include router outlet
this element informs angular to update
the application view with the component
for the selected route
you can add router link active attribute
if you want to style active link
one note the order of routes is
important because the router uses a
first match win strategy when matching
routes so more specific routes should be
placed above
less specific routes
often as a user navigates your
application you want to pass information
from one component to another to do so
you use the activated route interface
first import router activate a route and
paramap to your component
inject an instance of activated route by
adding it to your application's
constructor
update the ngoninit method to access the
activated route and track the id
parameter
now we need to adjust our routes to pass
the id param as well
in path add semicolon and name of your
parameter
and then we can add id values to our
links
that's how you pass and retrieve data
from one component to another
a well-functioning application should
gracefully handle when user attempts to
navigate to a part of your application
that doesn't exist
to add this functionality to your
application you set up a wildcard route
the angular route selects this route
anytime the requested url doesn't match
any router paths
to set up a wildcard route add the
following code to your routes definition
for the component property you can
define any component in your application
common choices include an application
specific page not found component
but here i'm just redirecting to the
first component
and now if you navigate to any random
path it will always give us first
component
as your application grows more complex
you may want to create routes that are
relative to the component other than
your route component
these types of nested routes are called
child routes this means you're adding a
second router outlet to your app because
it is in addition to the router outlet
in app component
in this example there are two additional
child components child a and child b
here first component has its own nav and
a second router outlet in addition to
the one in app component
also i'm gonna create two child routes
with the router links of child a and
child b
and give it a second router link
now i'll create two additional component
with angular cli and name their child a
component
and child b component
a child route is like any other route
in that it needs both a path and a
component
the one difference is that you place
child routes in a children array within
the parent route
now if we navigate to any of child
routes we get the corresponding child
component
use route guards to prevent users from
navigating to parts of an application
without authorization the following
route guards are available in angular
can activate
connect to a child
can deactivate
resold
and can load
create a service for your guard
ng generate guard your guard
in your guard class implement the guard
you want to use
the following example users can activate
to guard the route
now depending on your logic it can
return true or false usually it checks
if the user is logged in or does he have
privileges to access the page
in your routing module use the
appropriate property in your route
configuration
here can activate tells the router to
mediate navigation to this particular
route
now if we set the guard to false we
can't access the route otherwise we can
and that's all for routing for this
section
[Music]
after this one we are covering one even
more important concept and that is
angular forms let's start off with
template driven forms
i know it sounds impossible but there
were times when there was no internet or
even computer
so in those times we had to fill out
good old paper forms when we wanted to
visit a doctor or to apply for various
personal documents
so web forms are nothing different
except they're digital
angular supports two design approaches
for interactive forms
template driven forms are suitable for
small or simpler forms
while reactive forms are more scalable
and suitable for complex forms
this tutorial shows you how to build a
form from scratch
first
import forms module in your app root
module
first build our pet class which defines
a data model reflected in our form
i will have three properties id name and
specie
now let's import our class in the app
component
define species in species array
now create a model from the pet class
and pass the values for our path
here we're using dummy data but in your
real app you would use a service to get
the data from the api and to save it
also let's add submitted property which
will change depending on the state of
the form and on submit method
next in our html file we will create a
form that reflects our data model
create a form and inside it two divs for
two fields
first will be name input
and i'm adding label
and required attribute to our input
and the second one will be a select
which will loop through an array of
species to show all the values from the
array
same as for input
i'm adding label for select and also
i'll add required attribute
then i will use ng4 to load through all
the values
and display them
if you run the application right now you
see the list of species in the selection
control
the input elements are not yet bound to
data values or events so they are still
blank and have no behavior
the next step is to bind the input
controls to the corresponding path
properties with two-way data binding so
that they respond to the user input by
updating the data model and also respond
to programmatic changes in the data by
updating the display
the ng model directive declared in the
forms module lets you bind controls in
your template-driven form to properties
in your data model
add the ng model directive using two-way
data binding syntax
for the name use model.name
and for species
use
model.specie value
when you use ng model on an element you
must define a name attribute for that
element
angular uses the assigned name to
register the element with the ng-form
directive attached to the parent form
element
so in order to register our form add a
template reference variable with a value
of ng form
the pathform template variable is now a
reference to the ng-form directive
instance that governs the form as a
whole
in order to test our application place
the model object in our template with a
json pipe
now if you update your form films you
will see that model is being updated
now the user should be able to submit
this form after filling it
create a submit button on the bottom
the submit button at the bottom of the
form does nothing on its own but it does
trigger as form submit event because of
its type
submit
to respond to this event take the
following steps
bind the forms ng submit event property
to the pet form component on submit
method
use the template reference variable pet
form to access the form that contains
the submit button and create an event
binding
you will bind the form property that
indicates its overall validity to the
submit button's disabled property
run the application now
notice that the button is enabled
although it doesn't do anything useful
yet
delete the name value
this violates the required rule so it
disables the submit button
to show a response to form submission
you can hide the data entry area and
display something else in its place
wrap the entire form in a div and bind
its hidden property to the app component
submitted property
the main form is visible from the start
because the submitted property is false
until you submit the form
as this fragment from the app component
shows
to show something else while the form is
in submitted state add the following
html below the new div wrapper
add the properties that you updated and
the edit button if the user wants to
update the fields again
and now let's preview how it works
that's all about template-driven forms
[Music]
now in the next section we're gonna see
how we can take more control of our
forms and how to create reactive forms
[Music]
reactive forms provide a model driven
approach to handling form inputs whose
values change over time
each change to the form state returns a
new state which maintains the integrity
of the model between changes
let's add basic form control
to use react inform controls import
reactive forms module from angular forms
package and add it to your ng modules
import array
to register a single form control import
a form controller class and create a new
instance of form control to save as a
class property
use the constructor of form control to
set its initial value which in this case
is an empty string
by creating these controls in your
component class you get immediate access
to listen for update and validate the
state of the form input
after you create a control in the
component class you must associate it
with a form control element in the
template
update the template with the form
control using the form control binding
provided by form control directive which
is also included in the reactive forms
module
using the template binding syntax the
form control is now registered to the
name input element in the template
you can display the value in the
following ways
through the value changes observable
where you can listen for changes in the
forms value in the template using async
pipe or in the component class using the
subscribe method
or with the value property which gives
you a snapshot of the current value
the following example shows you how to
display the current value using
interpolation in the template
the displayed value changes as you
update the form control element
reactive forums have methods to change
the controls value programmatically
which gives you the flexibility to
update the value without user
interaction
the following example adds a method to
the component class to update the value
of the control to nancy using the set
value method
the template with a button to simulate a
name update
when you click the update name button
the value entered in the form control
element is reflected as its current
value
the 4 model is the source of truth for
the control so when you click the button
the value of the input is changed within
the component class overriding its
current value
forms typically contain several related
controls
reactive forms provide two ways of
grouping multiple related controls into
a single input form
first way a form group defines a form
with a fixed set of controls that you
can manage together and second way a
form array defines a dynamic form where
you can add and remove controls at run
time
import the form group and form control
classes from the angular forms package
create a property in the component class
named profile form and set the property
to a new form group instance
to initialize the form group provide the
constructor with an object of named keys
mapped to their control
for the profile form add two form
control instances with the names first
name and last name
the individual form controls are now
collected within a group
after you define a model you must update
the template to reflect the model in the
view
i'm adding two inputs and two labels
that match our model
the form control name input provided by
the form control name directive binds
each individual input to the form
control defined in form group
the form group directive listens for the
submit event emitted by the form element
and emits an ng submit event that you
can bind to a callback function
add an ng submit event listener to the
form tag with the unsubmit callback
method
the onsubmit method captures the current
value of profile form
here we will just log the form value
the submit event is emitted by the form
tag using the native dom event
you trigger the event by clicking a
button with submit type
this allows the user to press the enter
key to submit the completed form
add a button to the bottom of the form
to trigger the form submission
and that's all for reactive forms
in the next section we're gonna see how
we can improve our forms
so in this section we are covering form
validation
[Music]
this tutorial will show you how to
validate user input from the ui and
display useful validation messages in
both reactive and template-driven forms
anything that you want to store to your
database needs to have multiple levels
of validation
and i see validation the same as if
you're at an audition or job interview
something or rather someone is
presenting to you
and you decide will he pass or not
to add validation to a template driven
form you add the same validation
attributes as you would with native html
form
validation angular uses directives to
match these attributes with validator
functions in the framework
every time the value of a form control
changes angular runs validation and
generates either a list of validation
errors that results in an invalid status
or null which results in a valid status
i'll create a name string field inside
of our component class
then in our html file i'll add an input
text field
with required attribute and mean length
of 4.
i'm binding name input property to ng
model and i'm exporting ngmodel to a
local variable called name
ng model mirrors many of the properties
of its underlying form control instance
so you can use this in template to check
for control states such as valid and
dirty
the ngif of the div element reveals a
set of nested messages divs but only if
the name is invalid and the control is
either dirty or touched
each nested div can present a custom
message for one of the possible
validation errors
these are messages for required and mean
lead
now if you type something and leave the
field empty we will get the validation
error message and the same goes if we
enter value less than 4 characters long
in a reactive form the source of truth
is a component class instead of adding
validators through attributes in the
template you add validator function
directly to the form control model in
the component class
the same built-in validators that are
available as attributes in
template-driven forms such as required
and mean length are all available to use
as functions from the validator class
to update the validation form to be a
reactive form use some of the same
built-in validators
in this example the name control sets up
two built-in validators validators
required in validator's mean length
these validators are synchronous so they
are passed as the second argument notice
that you can support multiple validators
by passing the functions in as an array
this example also adds a getter method
in a reactive form you can always access
any form control through the get method
on its parent group but sometimes it's
useful to define getters as shorthand
for the template
in our template add form group to our
form
and now only thing that we need to
change in our template to make it
reactive is to remove ng model and to
bind our name control to form control
name
this form differs from the template
driven version in that it no longer
exports any directives
instead it uses the name getter defined
in the component class
notice that the required attribute is
still present in the template although
it's not necessary for validation it
should be retained for accessibility
purpose
we finally came to the end of this long
tutorial and we're gonna cover
communication using http client
imagine that you're running a tv station
or a newspaper and what if you lose
communication with your reporters
you would end up with a blank newspaper
or no news to broadcast
oh god it's the same thing with web apps
without back-end communication our apps
would be bad without informations or
instructions from the backend
most front-end applications need to
communicate with a server or http
protocol to download or upload data and
access other backend services
before you can use http client you need
to import angular http client module
most apps do so in the root app module
let's create data service most common
use case is to inject http client into
service and use it throughout the
application you can then inject http
client service as a dependency of an
application class as shown in this
example
now let's see how we can fetch data from
a server
to do that we're gonna use http client
get method
first inject http client into our
service
then create getdata method and inside of
this method we're going to fetch our
data
the get method takes two arguments the
endpoint url from which to fetch and an
options object that you use to configure
the request to add things like
parameters to your requests for this
tutorial i found a free cocktail api
service
the link will be in the description box
below
enter the url and no additional
parameters are required in this case
now in our app component we inject the
data service in the constructor
and inside of ngoniinet method let's
call our getdata method
because the service method returns an
observable the component subscribes to
the method's return value
i'm just going to console.log it
and that's how you get data from the
server
in an ideal world everything works as a
magic but we don't live in an ideal
world unfortunately and we lose
connection with api sometimes
so we need to handle errors when they
come
up if the request fails on the server
http client returns an error object
instead of a successful response
let's add a pipe on our get method and
use cache error to catch it
i'm going to lock the error for
development purpose and return throw
error with some message
this should be used in your application
to show the user that his request has
failed without notification they
wouldn't know what's happening
and don't forget to import missing
packages
now we can change the url to break the
request and to see the error we usually
don't want to see this view in our
applications but we need to be ready for
that when it happens
http client besides get also has a post
method for submitting data to server for
example if you are submitting a form
we have delete request for deleting data
from database obviously a put request
which replaces a resource with updated
data now most of the apis require an
authentication key with their requests
so let's see how we can add that
i found this load of rings database
which requires an auth key
let's create http options object with
the headers property
this property will be a new http headers
object and we will pass two properties
content type is application json which
means that we are using json as content
and authorization where we enter our api
key barrier is type of authorization and
followed by a key
in order to get your personal key you
need to register link is in the
description box below
now update the api endpoint
and if you try to call without passing
http options you can see that we get an
error
but if we add authorization
the request is successful
congratulations you watch all the way
through the end
this was very long tutorial and i hope
you learned a lot of new things
also don't forget to subscribe to
freecodecamp and if you want to see more
tutorials like this don't forget to
check out my channel my name is slovodan
and i see you guys in one of the next
videos or tutorials take care until then